no
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
muestran los zapatos por favor
no
no soy una gran persona de zapatos en
general al probablemente son lo último
en lo que pienso cuando se trata de un
atuendo pero dicen que se puede saber
más de alguien por sus zapatos y el
concursante número dos me gustan mucho
esos zapatos yo me pondría esos zapatos
también el concursante número cuatro
estos son muy bonitos tengo curiosidad
por saber qué es lo que acompaña el
resto no puedo decir mucho solo así
entonces qué tipo de música les gusta a
todos mis géneros favoritos son quizás
el rap como el nuevo álbum de cain y el
de donde también escucho pop como ariana
grande entre otros géneros
soy productor hago música de diferentes
géneros desde reggae hasta el hip hop y
la música house
soy aficionado al árabe pero también me
gusta mucho la música alternativa
escucho rock indie mis favoritos son
salieron a una banda llamada maxfield
también música de frank sinatra dean
martin y bailarín diría que el grupo
favorito los rolling stones y el artista
favorito de sweeting me gusta extender
cats y prince princess obviamente el
mejor músico de todos los tiempos así
que no diré nada más bien bien déjame
recordar déjame repasar voy a tener que
eliminar muy tristemente al concursante
número uno
número uno sal por favor
hola hola lo siento sin embargo tu ropa
es increíble yo también estoy bien tu
rostro no solo está inspirado en él
bueno está bien
[Música]
puedo mirar ahora
o bien el concursante número 5 nuestro
que esperaba en absoluto no sé yo sólo
esperaba que primero llevara pantalones
o algo más atlético sin embargo me gusta
me gusta mucho los colores muy original
el concursante número 3 es lo que
esperaba me gustaron sus selecciones
musicales así que muy prometedor puedo
hacerle una pregunta a todos ahora bien
a dónde iríamos en nuestra primera cita
y qué haríamos iríamos a dar un paseo en
auto probablemente en algún lugar cerca
de la costa conseguir esa agradable
brisa vespertina del océano que
mostraría mi música y tal vez cocinar
algo al terminar pues bien a mí me gusta
ir a miradores y acantilados y
simplemente observar las estrellas o
simplemente relajarme en el auto y luego
hablar para conocerte de verdad bien
pues yo me considero un gran romántico
voy a llevarte a cenar tal vez un lugar
que no haya probado antes o un lugar que
sé que es muy bueno y luego tal vez ir a
bailar o qué tipo de baile haríamos
bailes de swing bailes de salón puedo
bailar un poco de salsa sólo un poco
no es muy bueno pero podemos trabajar en
ello probablemente te llevaría a dar un
paseo a mi lugar favorito en autopista
en jesus christ y
probablemente haríamos un picnic allí y
hay un después un museo de arte en que
nos llevaría hasta ese lugar una
motocicleta si te parece bien nunca
estás en la parte trasera de una
motocicleta nunca es tarde yo elegiría
un autocine conduzco una camioneta así
que tengo muchas cosas para auto cine
colchón de aire mantas almohadas picnic
todo eso preparado preferiblemente una
película de terror si te gustan ese tipo
de cosas me encantan estropearlas
las dos
y sólo tenía uno bien tengo que repensar
ahora voy a eliminar el concursante
número 2
encantado de conocer
si fueron las respuestas y adiós así que
ahora va a ser el concursante
número 2 bien sí
muchas gracias y sobre la moda
sostenible trabajo en una tienda de
segunda vida si allí trabajó habría sido
una pareja amorosa
[Música]
me parece que la parte de arriba hace
juego con los pantalones aún así me
gusta mucho el conjunto del último tiene
un estilo realmente genial sí me gusta
la chaqueta de cuero va con la moto va
con la música rock todo tiene sentido
ahora
sí
nada sobre mí pues
parece muy cómodo yo tal vez una especie
de collar eso me gusta donde te ves en 5
años me voy en unos seis meses
a asia voy a iniciar un proyecto
empresarial en filipinas con mi amigo
estamos desarrollando viviendas
asequibles para que casi todo el mundo
pueda ir de vacaciones e intento hacer
más accesible que las personas puedan
visitar lugares hermosos y esa es una
gran respuesta sí es súper dulce me
gusta eso probablemente tatuando y
viajando al mismo tiempo actualmente
estoy en un entrenamiento de tatuaje no
sé espero eso me dé la oportunidad de
viajar y trabajar al mismo tiempo que te
llevo a los tatuajes y cuál fue tu
primer tatuaje bueno lo que me llevó a
tatuar fue el arte en general y he
estado dibujando toda mi vida tengo una
licenciatura en bellas artes simplemente
pensé que era una forma de ganar dinero
y hacer lo que me gusta y el primer
tatuaje tenía 17 años fue nueva york que
me hice una calavera en el interior del
bíceps
ahora mismo no tengo ningún tatuaje pero
quiero hacerme uno con el tiempo supongo
que soy bastante estacionario en
comparación con los demás me gustaría
abrir mi propio concesionario o empezar
a vender autos personalmente los autos
son mi pasión cuál es tu auto soñado y
eso es difícil soy fanático de mercedes
benz trabajé para ellos durante unos
cuatro años así que diría que tal vez um
a sls goldwing
la cual eliminaría esa hora
creo que la primera persona que voy a
eliminar es el concursante número 2
[Música]
es un placer conocerlo
gracias
dame 30 segundos dame 30 segundos
esto es difícil
siento que me gusta la ropa de ellos 2
así que ahora tengo que pensar en las
respuestas
voy a
eliminar el concursante número 2
estoy muy triste por ello
todo bien hola soy de queen queen
encantada lo siento fue muy difícil
puedo voltear
[Música]
hola que tal este nombre
sinceramente estoy muy emocionado por lo
que estás haciendo en el futuro con la
moda sostenible eso gracias me gustó lo
que ibas a hacer tu plan para 5 años me
gustó mucho espectacular y creo que fue
tu primera cita a la que me atrapó
porque sonaba divertida creo que
definitivamente hay muchos elementos que
me gustan la joyería nunca me ha gustado
pero me gusta me alegro de que te estés
anima si me estás animando
[Música]
jubilee vive intensamente